under gaze worth nothing I have nothing
to show for my degree I was done very
wrong by my school and I decided to
strike against to pay my student loan
back Corinthian College was a for-profit
school they preyed on minorities they
preyed on single parents they preyed on
low-income families the department
education allowed this school to
continue to run although they were under
investigation the education was supposed
to be high quality it was supposed to be
hands-on training I had a student
teaching me who had been there for maybe
two weeks more than me I had teachers
who would watch you cheat from each
other and give you full credit for it I
wanted to study being a medical
assistant I really enjoyed helping
people I really thought that I could you
know start a family I could buy a house
I could get a car I could you know do
the do the grown-up things in life and
unfortunately I I can hardly even rent a
place because because of my credit score
I don't want to share with people like a
lot of did sorry it's a
it's discouraging and some bear it's
embarrassing
yeah I'm 22 I guess I have that much
today us our generation is what's gonna
help the economy later on so we got
involved and decided to collectively
organize together and start a strike and
now we're up to 250 strikers it's almost
liberating for me to just to refuse to
pay that because it's not real it's not
it wasn't a real degree it's a big thing
I feel like this the student debt crisis
is going to be one of the next huge
things to to hit America
you